uh those first ones are pretty nice
those jordan ones dude let's be honest
yeah but jordan ones dude
from 1986. that's the ugliest sneaker
i've ever seen i'm not joking around
which one is that that oh that
that's not it come on man nobody's
wearing that daddy it's like a jordan
for a [ __ ] abominable snowman
like dude if i made a snowman i would
put those sneakers on it
those ones aren't bad right there i like
those ones those nikes right there
i don't mind that uh but those pink and
gray ones are [ __ ] hideous
yeah
uh like one of those ones what that
woman's got on those slip-on [ __ ]
things yeah those are like skechers type
[ __ ] that's nice
yeah those are gross dudes that blue one
that teal one is gross with the pink
it's gross
i gotta be honest with you some about i
was like i don't know i can't tell if
that's ugly or not